Prof: We're going to
begin today by going to the end
of my previous lecture and
taking up,
again, the topic of
Ginés being cross-eyed,
to give you my final thoughts
on that.
Then we're going to,
as promised,
move to the character among the
galley slaves that I call 'the
prisoner of sex',
and finally,
move on to the Sierra Morena,
to the woods and to the
complicated stories that take
place there.
Now, we said that Ginés'
cross-eyedness--
if such a word exists--is
monocular and convergent--
monocular meaning of one eye,
one eye goes into the other--
so this does not allow him to
perceive reality clearly,
but slanted,
by the conflicting angles of
his visual access.
It is a sort of--and this is
the main point of what I'm
trying to say--
it is a sort of innate or
congenital,
internal perspectivism,
prior to any perspectivism
based on the multiple points of
view provided by several
characters.
Perspectivism in Cervantes,
which as I have mentioned
before,
is a topic of Cervantes's
criticism,
presuppose the unified visions
of several characters who view
something like Mambrino's
helmet,
i.e.
the barber's basin,
and disagree on what that
happens to be.
Each sees reality in a way that
represents his or her point of
view and his or her way of
being,
but Ginés' being
cross-eyed suggests to me that
such individual visions are
already an abstraction and a
hasty assumption,
the assumption that each look
is singular and represents only
one individual.
But being cross-eyed means that
within each individual there are
conflicting views and therefore,
conflicting ways of seeing,
and this is very much inline
with the way that Cervantes'
characters behave,
at odds with themselves, often.
Now, so the global result is
not a unified but a conflicted
vision within each of the
character,
and I said that this kind of
double vision is called
diplopia.
It's an awful sounding word of
Greek origin,
diplopia.
So the new model I propose,
based on this observation that
Ginés is cross-eyed and
given it importance,
is that it's a new model of
conflictive being,
conflicting being within him or
herself,
capable of seeing
simultaneously in two ways,
as if there were already an
internal dialogue of sorts
within each of the characters.
This condition Cervantes
represents, as is usual with
him, in a very funny way.
When Ginés,
who was the first--
who jumped free,
remember--after they took away
the chain: "he leaped free
and is embarrassed [I'm quoting]
upon the plain,
and setting upon the fallen
commissary,
he took away his sword and his
gun,
with which leveling it,
first at one,
then at another,
without discharging it,
he cleared the field of all the
guard." Unquote.
Being cross-eyed,
is what I'm suggesting here,
allows Ginés to guard
each one of the guards at the
same time or one after another.
With one eye,
he's looking at one,
while with the other eye he's
looking at the other,
with a sword in one hand,
with a gun in the other.
And this is,
I think, the way that Cervantes
is representing this double
vision of Ginés.
If you don't read those lines
carefully you miss that subtle
point that Ginés can do
that because he is cross-eyed.
So with that,
having said that,
I move on to another prisoner,
who has been generally
overlooked, and who occupies all
of one paragraph.
It is the prisoner or the
galley slave that I call 'the
prisoner of sex',
and it shows Cervantes'
remarkable ability to create a
character with a few brush
strokes.
And I am going to read and
guide you to page 167 where the
passage is contained.
He has been asked,
as all the others,
why he is going to the galleys.
And he replies:
"I am going for making a
little too free with two
she-cousins-german of mine,
and with two other
cousins-german not mine [This
is,
of course, eighteenth century
English,
meaning that he was making it,
as it were,
with two cousins of his,
and two other girls,
who were cousins of each of
other but not of his.
I continue]:
in short, I carried the jest so
far with them all,
that the result of it was the
increasing of kindred so
intricately,
that no casuist can make it out.
The whole was proved upon me;
I had neither friends nor money;
my windpipe was in the utmost
danger;
I was sentenced to the galleys
for six years.
I submit--it is the punishment
of my fault;
I am young;
and life may last,
and time brings everything
about: if your worship
señor cavalier,
has anything about you to
relieve us [actually in the
original it's 'to relieve these
poor wretches,' he takes
distance from the others]
God will repay you in heaven,
and we will make it the
business of our prayers to
beseech him,
that your worship's life and
health may be as long and
prosperous,
as your goodly presence
deserves."
So he has been sentenced to the
galleys because he was having
simultaneous affair with four
women,
two of whom were his cousins,
and two others who were not,
who were cousins to each other.
And had a progeny,
a series of children whose
family ties were difficult to
untangle.
They were cousins,
brothers and sisters,
and so forth and so on,
as you can imagine.
Now, the historical reasons
behind this,
and Cervantes is very careful
in couching all of these stories
in very precise historical
reasons,
is that men were needed for the
galleys at the time because of
Spain's overseas adventures,
and so sentences were changed
to send more prisoners to the
galleys,
and the age limit was
lowered--I think it was to
sixteen or something like that.
So this is the reason behind it.
Now, he is brazen,
and to judge by his being good
in Latin--
oh, I forgot to read that at
the end,
where one of the guard's says
that he's a good Latiner,
that he's good in Latin and so
forth--
and wearing a robe it shows
that he's a law student,
and this is very significant.
There were many law students at
the time,
and they were masters of
rhetoric and syllogistic
thinking and arguing,
of course, this being the
skills that lawyers presumably
develop,
the kind of syllogism
that--you're too young maybe to
remember when President Clinton
was being quizzed about his
relationship with Monica
Lewinsky and he answered one of
the questions,
"It depends what 'is'
is," being evasive,
he wanted to have everything
defined.
He was just using.
So the other precise legal
background here is that he has
engaged in what was called
complex fornication.
There was simple and complex
fornication.
Simple fornication was
consensual sex between two
individuals of different sexes
who are unmarried.
That is simple fornication.
Complex fornication,
you can imagine,
one of the partners is married,
two of the partners are married
to other people,
they are of the same sex,
and so forth and so on,
and, of course,
the sentences for complex
fornication increased--
you see?
And here, he has engaged in
complex fornication because he
has committed incest having had
sex with his cousins,
two of them,
for good measure.
But his legal training is
evident here in that he's trying
to turn what is a criminal case,
incest, to put it in modern
terms, into a civil case.
It's a question of inheritance
law;
how are we going to figure out
the inheritance when these
children's family ties are so
complicated.
So as you can see,
he has subtly,
in his discourse,
tried to diminish his
culpability, but,
of course, he is guilty of
incest and therefore,
has been sent to the maximum
sentence,
six years in the galleys.
So he shuffles the question to
a question of inheritance law--
and you will be hearing a lot
about that today--
what is a case of incest,
a criminal case.
Incest is to make love or to
engage in sex with someone you
cannot marry according to Canon
law,
Canon law being religious law,
and according to Canon law
there are all kinds of
prohibitions,
but cousins you are not
supposed to marry,
although dispensations can be
obtained from the church and all
of that--
of course, you cannot marry
your mother,
you cannot marry your sister,
and so forth,
but it goes down to your
cousin, you cannot marry a nun,
all of that is under the
prohibition of incest.
But certainly here,
he has been guilty of incest
and this is why he is being sent
to the galleys.
You also notice that he says,
'Well,
this is the proper punishment
for my crime,' as if he knew,
being already a budding lawyer
and saying,
I accept this,' and he says
that, 'Well, life will go on,
I'm young, I'll come back from
the galleys,' and so forth,
which was very unlikely that
he'll come back alive and then
he disappears.
But not before jumping on Don
Quixote and taking the basin
from his head and whacking him a
few times with it.
That's the last we hear of this
prisoner of sex who is a kind of
libertine in the making.
And he and the others disappear
into the woods,
into the same woods where
Marcela disappeared,
by the way, and into the same
woods into which Don Quixote and
Sancho are going to go also
running away from the law.
So notice, again,
what I said at the beginning,
how Cervantes has created this
rather complex character in just
one paragraph and by just his
speech,
what he says and how he says it.
So now we go into the Sierra
Morena and enter what is really
the core of Part I of the
Quixote,
which is made up of all of
these stories that we'll be
hearing about in the next few
classes and that you're reading
now.
They are running away from the
Holy Brotherhood,
about which I've spoken several
times before,
because they are fugitives from
justice,
and this is the overarching
plot, they are running away from
justice,
in reality, they are running
away from justice,
but it's in the real time of
the period.
They are, in fact,
as you will see later when they
are captured,
being pursued by the Holy
Brotherhood.
They are criminals who,
in some way,
are expiating their sins in the
woods.
The woods are a kind of
labyrinth or a vision of hell,
remindful in some aspects of
Dante's Inferno,
some of its features,
such as the asperity of the
landscape,
the cracks, and so forth.
They are as far as possible
from civilization.
It is a world of disorder and
madness;
it is also the
despoblado,
the unpopulated,
which in Spanish law meant
areas not covered or protected
by the law, the
despoblado.
These are areas where the law
and where the power of the
state, of the crown,
did not reach.
Cervantes uses those areas to
send his characters into danger,
into confusion,
and into violence.
Now, the Sierra Morena will be
the setting of a series of
tightly related episodes all
dealing with the question of
love and more mundanely with the
issue of marriage.
Now, the interpolated stories
that come after the Marcela and
Grisóstomo episode which
prefigured them and Rocinante's
disastrous flirtation make up,
as I said, the core of the Part
I of the Quixote.
These stories peak and are
resolved,
for the most part,
together with the main plot,
the plot involving Don Quixote
and Sancho which,
as I said, resolves itself when
he is captured and sent back
home.
This is a set of narrative
trends tightly woven around two
of the principal drives in the
book.
One, Don Quixote's love quest
for Dulcinea and the series of
crimes and misdemeanors
perpetrated by the hidalgo and
his squire,
that lead to his pursuit and
apprehension.
The interpolated stories have
in common with the central plot,
and with the Marcela and
Grisóstomo interlude,
and with each other the
perpetration of offenses due to
passion which result in
injuries,
to honor, body and property,
and with the resulting need for
restitution,
recompense, requital,
pardon or revenge.
In all of them,
marriage looms as the
inevitable and most appropriate
form of reparation,
as well as the most effective
kind of narrative closure.
Marriage is also in this
context a form of punishment.
Now, these stories involve
potentially unequal marriages
and most of them contain
violence of some sort.
Unequal in the sense that the
individuals involved come from
different social classes,
and that difference is what
motivates many of the conflicts,
but not all.
But although penal law,
again, looms over the episodes,
the penal law applied to
criminals like Don Quixote and
Sancho,
the most developed legal aspect
in them,
in this stories,
derives from testamentary law,
something already at issue in
the Marcela-Grisóstomo
conflict.
Remember how much importance
was given to the fact that they
had both inherited wealth,
and how they had inherited;
she being a woman,
he being a man,
and so forth.
Inheritance and marriage codes
both regulating succession drive
and constrain the characters.
Restitution and compensation
cooperate to make whole what
they damage in the process of
channeling their desires--
if you know something about
law, you know that 'to make you
whole' is to bring restitution
to you for some damage or loss
that you have incurred.
So the same symbolic topology
reappears,
that we have seen already
between the road and the inn,
now, here, it is between the
woods and the inn,
between the inn and the
wilderness,
which will be also a good way
to translate despoblado,
the wilderness.
And the going back and forth
from one to the other is
punctuated,
often, by interruptions in the
narratives,
interruptions that we will
consider carefully later today.
Marriage has to do with the
law, of course,
as well as with the closure of
stories.
So it is an important
structural issue too,
structural in terms of
narrative structure.
Marriage is the ending of many
tales and plays,
'and they married and lived
happily after' so to speak,
the end of many tales.
That's how things are resolved,
how order is restored,
and succession is in insured.
The questions of love and
marriage,
which were important issues,
both from a social and literary
point of view,
surface here as in the episode
of Grisóstomo and
Marcela,
I underline,
through stories of young
people.
The young people,
I have written their names
here,
and I should get out of the way
so that we have them clear,
is Cardenio,
Luscinda, Fernando and Dorotea.
I forget, often,
to say Don Fernando,
but it says Don Fernando in the
text because he is entitled to
the 'don.'
Now, these are decisive
episodes in which Cervantes is
dealing with love and marriage
at a significant point in
western history,
both in social and literary
terms.
Is love an integral or even
necessary part of marriage,
or is marriage principally a
social and economic contract?
Do young people have the right
to choose whom they marry?
All of these questions have
obvious answers today,
but not then,
and not for a long time.
Even now, well into the
twentieth century in some
societies, marriages were
arranged.
I remember, Gayatri Spivak,
a well-known critic and
theoretician,
telling me--she's from
India--that her mother had only
heard her father's voice once,
in another room,
before the day which she
married him.
The arrangements were being
made and she heard the voice of
this man who would be her
husband for the rest of her
life.
These are things that are seen
very, very far from our lives
today, but not at the time.
The issue of marriage was being
debated in the sixteenth
century,
and it will continue to be
debated through the centuries,
and it is an important topic in
Cervantes because it has to do
with social,
legal, and also with the issue
of love.
Now, significantly it is now
that Sancho learns to his
astonishment Dulcinea's real
identity: Ah,
she is the daughter of Lorenzo
Corchuelo!
Of course he knows who this
woman is!
Is that Dulcinea?
The story of Don Quixote's love
for her is the background for
the stories of Cardenio,
Luscinda, Fernando and Dorotea,
because Don Quixote's love of
Aldonza Lorenzo could have led
to an unequal marriage,
that of an aristocrat,
even if a minor aristocrat,
with a country lass,
which is--and unequal
marriages,
as I've already said,
it's one of the constants in
all of the stories in the Sierra
Morena and reflect the society
in flux,
where there is insipient class
mobility.
The sixteenth century Spain was
called by Américo Castro,
a great historian and critic,
a 'conflictive age,' and part
of the conflict was this social
effervescence,
this social instability,
about which I'll speak more in
the course of the semester--
Aldonza appeals to Don Quixote
or Alonso Quixano because of her
manly qualities,
which he transforms into
sublime courtly love,
into a sublime courtly love;
beauty.
She is manly,
in the sense that,
as we will learn,
she's brawny,
strong, used to hard labor in
the fields.
I think that this is the
fetishistic appeal she has for
Don Quixote,
that, as opposed to the women
in his class,
one supposed--who are civilized
and so forth--
Aldonza would be more sexual in
a more physical and open way.
So this is what is,
I think, behind his infatuation
with her.
What does Don Quixote's love of
Aldonza tell us about love?
Aldonza/Dulcinea.
This is one of those lessons
for life.
I told you in the first
lecture, you might learn in
reading the Quixote,
the Quixote is also
about life, your lives.
What we learn from Don
Quixote's passion for Aldonza,
whom he turns into Dulcinea,
is that when in love we invent
the object of our desire,
and that that object depends on
the projection of our own inner
demons.
So this is something to learn
for life.
I told you, you would learn
quite a few things,
I'll be pointing out others;
but this is perhaps the most
important and urgent for you to
learn, at least today.
Okay.
Let us set up the cast of main
characters in the stories in the
Sierra Morena,
so that we can untangle this as
much as we can,
because it can get complicated,
and I'm going to also unravel
the socioeconomic background
behind all of this.
Let us begin with Cardenio.
Cardenio, the name suggests,
cárdeno--it means
purple, bright purple,
it says bright purple with
passion.
In terms of literary history,
Cardenio is a minor Orlando
Furioso,
Ariosto's protagonist in the
poem of that name,
who goes berserk when he
suspects that Angélica
has betrayed him with Medoro,
a youthful Moor.
This is that famous poem,
Orlando Furioso,
that I have mentioned several
times,
and that if you're a literature
major or a literature person you
should read at some point.
Cardenio is mad as a result of
a lover's treason.
He roams nearly naked,
an image of his savagery,
of his regression to the world
of nature;
he's a wild man in the
Renaissance tradition--in the
Renaissance, the figure of the
wild man appears often.
Madness and love are embodied
in Cardenio as they are in the
mad knight in Don Quixote,
because Cardenio is also a
double of Don Quixote,
and, in fact,
Don Quixote has a feeling of
the uncanny when he meets
Cardenio for the first time.
He says--I'm quoting from page
183--
Don Quixote,
quote: "advanced to
embrace him and held him in a
good space,
very close between his arms as
if he had been acquainted with
him a long time."
Unquote.
Perhaps he had been acquainted
with Cardenio being acquainted
with himself,
and this is what the line
suggests.
So Don Quixote discovers in
Cardenio like a sort of double.
Cardenio is a poet.
We discover this because of the
little bag they find all rotten
in the woods--
Don Quixote and Sancho--that
contains a book of poems and
texts by Cardenio.
We have, again,
a literary text read in the
novel as we did with
Grisóstomo's song,
remember that episode.
Like Grisóstomo,
Cardenio is a Petrarchan or a
Garcilaso-like poet,
sick with love--Petrarca,
the great Italian poet,
about whom you have all heard
is the,
one could say almost the
creator of modern poetry;
fourteenth century.
And Garcilaso,
whom I have mentioned before,
I think, but if not I mention
him again,
a disciple of Petrarch,
was the great Spanish poet of
the sixteenth century who
brought about the whole
revolution in poetic language,
in the Spanish language.
Sixteenth century,
Garcilaso lived from about 1501
to 1536, a very short life.
So Don Quixote is very happy to
have found this text,
and very curious about who the
author might be,
whereas Sancho is very happy to
have found a hundred gold coins.
And as you may have noticed,
Sancho is not very interested
in discovering who the owner of
the bag is,
because he doesn't want to have
to return the money.
Now, Cardenio and Luscinda
belong to the low nobility.
They are hidalgos,
like Don Quixote,
with sufficient wealth to make
their marriage desirable.
Both would gain,
she would gain social status,
because Cardenio's status is
higher, and he will gain wealth
because she is rich,
like Marcela.
Her estate would become
Cardenio's dowry guaranteeing
succession,
a reassuring prospect to her
parents,
because she is a woman and
there will be,
again--as in the case of
Marcela--there will be some
concern about the legacy being
lost.
The added capital would even
improve the lineage,
of course.
Dorotea, on the other hand,
is a commoner.
She is the rich farmer's
daughter, and she's far below
Don Fernando's status,
and marrying her would anger
Don Fernando's father because
she is his vassal.
Her name, as you may have
already noticed,
rhymes with Dulcinea.
We will see other instances
where Cervantes uses rhyme
echoes of this nature to
establish connections.
So rhyming with Dulcinea there
is something of a mirroring,
or echoing effect here,
a version of what Don Quixote's
and Dulcinea's romance could
have been,
I told you, the same
relationship,
except that Don Quixote is old.
The duke, that is,
Fernando's father,
is so wealthy that while the
increase of the estate would be
welcome, it would not be much of
an incentive.
Now, so much for Cardenio for
now and Luscinda.
Now, I move to Fernando,
or Don Fernando,
who is the most really
complicated of these characters.
He's not exactly a hero, no.
He is the character most vexed
by judicial and economic
pressures,
who are the source of most of
the troubles here,
having seduced Dorotea and
married Luscinda under false
pretenses.
He is guilty of estupro,
of rape,
and the priest,
at some point,
plans to denounce him,
whereupon he will become a
fugitive from justice like Don
Quixote.
Fernando's actions have sent
Cardenio and Dorotea into the
wilderness,
and left Luscinda in a
dangerous situation,
from which she also wants to
escape,
but she's abducted by Fernando
in that story that is told sort
of laterally.
And if Cervantes would have
gone into that story we would
have had an endless sequence of
stories,
so it's just left hanging,
what happens to her when she's
abducted from a convent,
and so forth and so on.
Don Fernando is a Don Juan
type, thinking of Don Juan,
the seducer,
first appeared in western
literature in a play by Tirso de
Molina,
a Spanish playwright of the
seventeenth century.
Fernando has caused injury to
Cardenio and Dorotea's families,
not just to them individually,
to each one of the young
people,
by comprising their honor and
estate,
meaning their social status and
economic position.
There is an implicit cause,
an implicit,
subtle, but strong cause for
Fernando's criminal actions.
Don Fernando is an anxious
segundón.
I have the word here.
It comes from the word
'segundo' in Spanish,
which means 'second'.
'Segundón' means
a second-born son.
Now, to explain Don Fernando's
socioeconomic status,
I must expound a little bit on
a Spanish institution,
the mayorazgo,
which is that word I have here.
In the Middle Ages Castilian
law had elaborated the
institution of the
mayorazgo,
an entailed state,
a mass of wealth and property
whose integrity and continuity
was guaranteed by exceptional
testamentary laws.
An entailed state,
in law, is to limit the
inheritance of property to a
specific line of heirs in such a
way that it cannot be legally
transferred--
I'm just giving you the
definition from Webster's
because not everybody knows what
an entailed state is.
As the name implies,
mayorazgo,
'hijo mayor':
hijo/son,
mayor/eldest son;
mayorazgo.
The mayorazgo consisted
in the privileging of first-born
males in matters of inheritance.
He, the first-born son,
inherited the title and the
bulk of the endowment.
The mayorazgo was an
entailment devised to ensure the
accumulation and retention of
wealth within one family by
preventing its dispersal through
marriages--
because if you had three sons
and each inherited the same,
and each married a different
woman,
of course, then the estate
begins to be dispersed and
diminished.
By the middle of the twelfth
century, the king allowed the
establishment of
mayorazgos that comprised
entire villages.
A mayorazgo could also
be a royal grant from the king
as reward for some special deed.
In the Siete
Partidas--this is a word,
something you better learn,
as I told you,
you were going to learn some
details about Spanish history
and culture,
essentially seven books.
The Siete Partidas is a
thirteenth century legal code
that is the foundation of all
Spanish law--
The legal foundation of the
mayorazgo was ultimately
grounded--
because how do you ground this,
I mean on what?
Why the first born?--by making
specific mention of God's
command to Abraham to sacrifice
Isaac, his first and most
beloved son.
So the ultimate authority was
the Bible.
The Partidas,
Siete Partidas,
also explicitly allowed the
testator,
that is, the one whose legacy
is being passed down,
to forbid his heir from
alienating the inheritance by
sale or other means,
obliging him to pass it on to
his own first born son,
and this legislation continued.
In the sixteenth century,
commoners were allowed to begin
mayorazgos,
and so forth.
So the proliferation of these
mayorazgos generated a
class of segundones or
second-born sons who were left
out of the patrimony--
you see what I mean?
If only the first born could
inherit,
and of course,
families had many sons and
daughters and so forth,
there were a lot of
segundones--
They had the social status,
their usually illustrious names
conferred upon them but not
financial substance or position
in society and an uncertain
future.
Elliott writes in Imperial
Spain, page 114,
which I think you must have
gotten all ready--I hope:
"Just under these two
groups of magnates [writes
Elliott, grandees and
títulos],
who formed the élite of
the Spanish aristocracy,
came a group which differed
from them in having no corporate
entity of its own,
but which none the less enjoyed
an acknowledged position in the
social hierarchy.
This group consisted of the
segundones--the younger
sons of the great houses.
These possessed no title of
their own,
and were generally victims of
the mayorazgo system
which reserved the bulk of the
family wealth to their elder
brothers.
Since their resources tended to
be limited,
they were likely to devote
themselves in particular to
careers in the Army or the
Church,
or to serve the Crown as
diplomats and
administrators."
Unquote.
The term
segundón,
by the way, by virtue of its
suffix is an augmentative,
is derogatory--g
randulón,
if you know Spanish,
is a lummox;
regalón,
someone who's spoiled;
coquetón, a flirt;
empollón, a nerd;
huevón,
lazy bones, and so forth.
Some of these are not very nice
words for you to learn in this
class, but it clearly points to
the embarrassing position;
you see?
I'm trying to give you the
background so you understand
Fernando's situation--
It clearly points to the
embarrassing position of someone
who can,
because of his heritage,
act with the self sufficiency
of his class,
but has little substance to
back it up.
The way out of the situation
was contained in a refrain of
the times, "Iglesia,
mar o casa real."
We will encounter it later in
the captive's tale,
where it is applied to the sons
of a man.
It meant that the
segundón could go
into the church,
obtaining a position of some
importance because of his
family's connection;
'mar,' he could go out
to sea, to seek adventures and
to seek wealth,
go to the colonies,
and so forth;
or 'casa real,' attach
himself to the court or to the
court of a grandee,
of someone who is important.
So cut off from their parents'
legacies,
the segundones became
social and economic climbers,
anxiously trying to make up for
their deficiency in status.
In the Spain of the sixteenth
and seventeenth centuries they
became a class on to themselves,
a laborious one,
one should say,
desperately seeking social and
economic advancement.
Don Fernando's situations and
actions betray all of the
features of this class.
Don Fernando is a
segundón,
the second son of Duke Ricardo.
In fact, the text reads in
Spanish, "Un hijo
segundo del duque,"
the duke's second son.
It meant all of the sons who
were not the first born;
it wasn't only the second son,
but also the third,
the fourth, the fifth,
they were all
segundones,
so the segundón
is essentially he who is not
first,
the only position with
entitlement.
When Cardenio appears in
Fernando's home remember,
he is summoned by the duke,
explicitly to be the companion
of his older brother,
who is in line to be the
father's successor and is all
ready a marquis,
Don Fernando ingratiates
himself with a visitor and wins
him over to his side.
Cardenio is like a rival,
or someone who reminds Don
Fernando of the role that he
would be called upon to play if
he chose casa real,
to the join the house of a
grandee.
He could be a competitor in
that, by becoming the ally of
his older brother,
he could come closer to wealth
and power than Don Fernando
himself,
prevented as he is by law from
acquiring them from his father.
Don Fernando is the odd-man
out, literally number three,
in this case,
which is worse than second.
So he lures Cardenio away and
soon finds himself as his rival
for Luscinda's favors.
His seduction of Dorotea could
have an economic motive too,
when he seduces Dorotea,
even if he leaves her at first.
In fact, when he does agree to
marry her later,
Don Fernando is potentially
founding a state that could,
conceivably could,
become a mayorazgo of
his own if it is rich enough and
wealthy enough.
So restitution takes on a whole
new meaning when viewed from
this perspective.
So readers of Cervantes's time
would have easily and
immediately recognized all of
the testamentary conflicts
involved in Don Fernando's
actions and how the law impinges
on his frantic love life.
It is his anxiety that drives
him to this frantic love life.
The economic,
social and ultimately judicial
context that was the background
of the Marcela-Grisóstomo
episode is greatly expanded then
here,
to encompass deep social and
economic issues in Castile
during the sixteenth century.
The judicial situation is
accurate and precise.
The source of the conflict in
which Don Fernando,
Cardenio, Luscinda and Dorotea
are entangled is very precise.
The impending marriage of
Luscinda and Cardenio is one
that is, again,
dictated, by circumstances,
as well as by mutual
attraction.
Cardenio says that Luscinda is
a maiden 'not only well born,
but as rich as I am.'
The description he gives of
their youth and early love is
like the implicit blue print for
the marriage of Marcela and
Grisóstomo,
only that it was nearer to
taking place.
Actually, their marriage was
very near to taking place when
Fernando intervenes.
But the ambition of social
advancement first postponed the
marriage,
because Cardenio's father feels
that he should go and answer the
duke's summons,
and then Luscinda's parents are
very interested in her marrying
Don Fernando,
because it would be a leap in
social class.
So, in fact,
Cardenio accuses Luscinda of
acting out of economic and
social interest and this is why
she left him,
and this is the source of his
feeling of betrayal that has
sent him into the woods.
Now, we continue with the cast:
Dorotea.
Dorotea is the victim of
Fernando's treachery but she's
not a passive character--
I told you Cervantes's women
characters tend not to be
passive--
and her actions are also
dictated by the economic and
legal determinations that drive
the others.
She's the daughter of commoners
who are,
however, all Christians,
and the characters boast of
this at a time when being
suspected of having some Jewish
or Moorish blood background
could be a disabling condition
in the Spain of the time,
so they are very proud,
old Christians,
wealthy, and so capable of
social advancement.
Her father is Clenardo,
the Rich, a great name,
Clenardo, the Rich,
and he and Dorotea's mother
have great ambitions for their
daughter.
In fact, when Dorotea makes up
a story that we'll talk about
soon when she's disguised as
Princess Micomicona she reveals
that she is fearful of Fernando
taking away her wealth,
and she--if you remember,
her characterization in
detail--
she's the one who ran the farm;
she says she's the one who did
all of the administrative work
in the farm.
So while Dorotea is a woman and
a vassal,
she is well aware of her rights
and legitimate aspirations,
not to mention what an asset
her own physical beauty can be--
we'll be talking about her
physical beauty in the next
class--
when Don Fernando sneaks into
her chamber determined to
possess her by any means,
she makes the decision to
surrender,
motivated by love,
pragmatism and greed.
In telling her story to the
priest, the barber and Cardenio,
Dorotea repeats what she told
herself at that crucial point.
She's telling the story of what
she thought at the moment that
Fernando was pressing the issue,
when he snuck into her room.
She told herself:
"Well: I shall not be the
first,
who, by the way of marriage,
has risen from a low to a high
condition,
nor will Don Fernando be the
first,
whom beauty,
or rather blind affection,
has induced to take a wife
beneath his quality.
Since then I neither make a new
world,
nor a new custom,
sure I may be allowed to accept
this honour,
which fortune throws in my way,
even though the inclination he
shows for me should last no
longer than the accomplishment
of his will;
for in short,
in the sight of God,
I shall be his wife.
Besides, should I reject him
with disdain,
I see him prepared to set aside
all sense of duty,
and to have recourse to
violence: and so I shall remain
dishonored,
and without excuse,
when I am censured by those,
who do not know how innocently
I came into this strait.
For what reasons can be
sufficient to persuade my
parents, and others,
that this cavalier got into my
apartment without my
consent?"
So she draws a balance and
decides that the best thing is
simply to consent.
Of course, she has made him
swear that they are going to
marry,
and she has made him swear in
front of her maid,
who was the one who let him in,
that he would marry and in the
Spain of the time--
I will talk about this much
more--secret marriages were
allowed,
meaning, if you told your
beloved in the darkness of night
in a fit of passion that you
wanted to marry her,
and she said yes,
you were, you were married,
because God is everywhere and
God is listening,
so therefore,
presumably you are married.
Of course, the temptation not
to abide by this marriage vows
was great,
and the debates about it in the
Council of Trent,
as we will have reason to
discuss in classes concerning
other marriage situations in
Part II were great.
So Dorotea is faithfully,
following both religious
doctrine and Castilian law which
condoned premarital sexual
relationships after a betrothal,
such as the one she has forced
Don Fernando to make.
He has sworn to marry her not
only before God,
but before herself and her
servant.
When she pleads her case at the
inn,
Dorotea invokes this oath,
appeals to Don Fernando's
conscience,
and assures him that,
by law, he's not compromising
his or his family's status
because nobility is transmitted
by the father,
not the mother's blood in
Castile--as we had occasion to
see in the case of
Grisóstomo and Marcela.
She convinces Don Fernando with
a speech that has as much verve
as Marcela's,
and is also couched in forensic
rhetoric and terminology.
So this is what is behind the
legal, socioeconomic background
of these stories,
about which we will talk more.
But I'm now going to speak
briefly, and in conclusion,
about one important aspect that
I mentioned before,
and that is interruptions.
You will have noticed that all
of these stories,
or that many of the stories,
are interrupted at some point.
The whole novel is interrupted.
In chapter VIII,
when the narrator claims to
have run out of text--
so that is perhaps the most
famous interruption in western
literature--
but there have been many other
interruptions;
the story of Marcela and
Grisóstomo being told by
Vivaldo,
and Ambrosio,
and others, is interrupted
several times,
but the most--and also we have
the proleptic interruption--
very funny interruption of
Sancho telling his story about
Torralba and her boyfriend and
the goats having to cross the
river and all of that--
remember that interruption?
But here, we have other
interruptions.
The most important and the most
spectacular is that of Cardenio.
Cardenio says,
and I won't read you the text
because you have it there and
you must remember it,
that he will tell the story,
but he will not be interrupted;
he does not want to be
interrupted with questions or
anything, so that that is the
precondition for his telling the
story.
But, of course,
at some point he mentions
Amadís de Gaula,
and that is simply too much for
Don Quixote to resist,
and he breaks in,
and interrupts Cardenio,
and Cardenio goes berserk.
He goes berserk,
and he brings up this story
about Queen Madasima having had
an affair with a lowly surgeon--
surgeons at the time did not
have a very high status--
and, of course,
attacks Don Quixote and Sancho,
and runs wild.
What is behind all of these
interruptions and there are
others?
What is behind all of these
interruptions is that they allow
for a certain truth to come out,
because what Cervantes is
showing that stories have a sort
of a self generating thrust,
that they follow a certain
script, and that they veil the
truth instead of telling it,
and that unless the teller is
interrupted,
the truth does not come out.
So what is the truth here?
The truth here,
in the case of Cardenio,
is that he has this paranoid
fantasy that Fernando has
already possessed Luscinda,
and that therefore,
Luscinda is not fit for
marriage with him.
It is unclear whether this
happened,
but the story that Cardenio
tells, translated into
literature,
is that this Queen Madasima had
this affair with this surgeon.
The idea of the surgeon,
of cutting, is obviously a
story of deflowering that is
deep in his mind,
and that Luscinda has been
deflowered by Fernando.
So he has transformed that
story in his fantasy into that
paranoid fantasy,
that what it reveals truly what
is in his subconscious.
This is similar to what we had
in the case of Don Quixote
making up that chivalric
romance;
that in telling the story,
in this case,
interrupting the story,
it reveals another story.
What the Quixote,
as a book, shows us is how to
read stories.
It is a primer on how to read
stories.
This is the second lesson for
life that you learn here even,
or particularly,
if you're going to be a lawyer.
Why?
Lawyers do not allow witnesses
to go on speaking for a long
time,
they're taught to interrupt
them, because a witness can go
on and let the story get away,
and create facts that don't
exist, and so forth--
The story that I always tell
when I get to this point is one
that happened many years ago,
and that you are too young to
remember,
but it's the story of Susan
Smith.
You may not have heard of Susan
She lived in a town in South
Carolina.
She had two children,
and she claimed that she had
been stopped at a traffic light
in her town,
and a black man had gotten into
her car,
and pushed her out,
and run away with her children,
and she came on TV tearfully
for almost a week.
There was a whole manhunt all
over the United States to try to
capture this abductor of the two
children,
who of course,
claiming that he was black,
added a racist component to
this whole thing,
until a certain sheriff broke
into her story and asked her
questions,
and it turned out that Susan
Smith had driven her car with
her two children into a lake,
and gotten out,
and killed the children and
just made the car disappear
because she had a lover,
a 'Fernando' of this South
Carolina town,
who was wealthy and a man about
town,
debonair, but didn't want to
marry a woman who had two
children;
Susan Smith was divorced.
So this came out,
when she was interrupted,
after having been on TV
tearfully telling the whole
story--
so if you interrupt a story
being told,
a story gathering momentum from
within itself,
you may get the real story to
emerge.
And this is what's happening in
the interruption of all of these
stories, which happens over and
again in the Quixote.
So what is most important to
remember from these interrupted
tales is to look for the story
not being told,
or for the story being told
obliquely,
as we did when considering Don
Quixote's invention of the
generic chivalric romance,
which was a roundabout way of
speaking about his own anxieties
and about his lack of social
status.
This is why in the
psychoanalytic session,
the analyst will interrupt you,
and ask you questions,
'Oh, what did you say about
mommy?
Hmm...
What did you say about daddy?
Hmm...'
And doesn't let you go on.
It's in that give and take that
the truth may emerge.
So this is what this book is
telling us.
We will see this narrative
device appear,
again, when Dorotea,
disguised as Princess
Micomicona,
makes up a story that is really
that of her own turbulent love
affair with Fernando.
She cannot make up a fictional
story without this emerging in
the background,
and there are little details
that betray that that's the
story.
So the Quixote is among
many other things:
a book about how to read,
how to interpret stories,
and in life we are surrounded
by stories of all kinds,
not just in literature.